les allemands sont aux portes d'arras
plus tôt ce matin nous devons nous
rendre à thiais nous allons
provisoirement abandonné nos champs et
nos maisons
qu'est ce que je fais du tic alors qu'il
est le père du petit doit être toujours
sous les bombardements
son premier et jusqu'à viable
mon papa va venir me chercher il me l'a
promis il nous reste des vivres pour
encore deux ou trois jours seulement ne
savons pas sur quoi on pourra compter
dans les visages que nous traverserons
mon papa nous avons fait halte ici pour
nous reposer je t'embrasse mis en fort
knox
pour cette soirée un peu particulière
monsieur le maire a décidé d'offrir un
verre à tout le monde
à
ouais
woodcock
et
j'ai commis une grave erreur
jamais j'en rêvais vous emmener son et
route et nous fait revivre tout ça